eine holzernte maschine auf den
harpstedter holztagen bäume werden zu
kleinholz um damit die gute stube zu
heizen
viele hier sind überzeugt dass sei
umweltfreundlich und gut fürs klima
es ist er letztendlich auch co2 neutral
alles was man beim kamin wieder raus
haut das haben vorher die bäume
aufgenommen von daher für die umwelt ist
es definitiv eine gute sache ja es ist
ja ein co2 co2 neutraler kreislauf das
was der boden hat gibt auch beim
verbrennen wieder frei nur ein kleiner
balken für die co2 emissionen von
scheitholz für ernte und transport im
vergleich zu öl oder gas scheint holz
der klimafreundlichste brennstoff zu
sein mit abstand
mit diesen zahlen hantiert auch hermann
spellmann er ist vorsitzender des
wissenschaftlichen beirats für
waldpolitik beim
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerium und ein
einflussreicher mann der forstwirtschaft
dass in deutschland rund die hälfte des
holz aufkommens verbrannt wird ist nach
spelmanns auffassung ein wertvoller
beitrag zum klimaschutz
es wird ja sehr viel holz aus dem forst
geholt um es zu verbrennen
das wird besser als es ist auf jeden
fall besser zu brennen ich weiß nicht ob
sie selbst auch einen kamin also ich hab
auch im kameni verbrauch im jahr sechs
kubikmeter ich habe eine viel geringere
gasrechnung und das ist eben ein
nachwachsender rohstoff
das was sie hier anders oder an erdöl
nehme das sind ja fossile brennstoffe
holz verbrennen billig und auf jeden
fall besser als glas oder öl
das ist nicht so das ist viel
komprimierter und erzeugt in der einheit
um also wärme zu erzeugen viel weniger
co2 als als brennholz bäume zu fällen um
sie zu verfeuern sei schlecht fürs klima
sagen der förster lutz feser und der
professor für nachhaltige entwicklung
kritisch
gemeinsam mit 800 wissenschaftler
fordern sie die regierung dürfe den co2
ausstoß durch holzverbrennung nicht
länger schön rechnen
es ist doch eigentlich ganz einfach zu
verstehen wenn ein baum 100 jahre
wachsen muss und denn derzeit co2
fixiert und den kohlenstoff verbindet
und wir diesen baum dann zu kamin zeiten
machen und diese kamin seite in ein paar
stunden verbrennen ist der kunststoff
innerhalb dieser kurzen zeit frei
gesetzt dann braucht es im besten fall
wieder 100 jahre damit ein ähnlicher
baum an der gleichen stelle steht
unter diesem vorzeichen ändert sich die
rechnung durch holzverbrennung entstehen
viel mehr co2 emissionen als bei der
verbrennung von öl und sogar fast das
doppelte als bei gas bei gleicher
energieausbeute wenn sie unterwegs sind
sie in die wald ökologen abgeschlagene
bäume tiefe schneisen und ausgedünnte
forsten
dabei könnten wälder eine viel größere
rolle beim klimaschutz spielen wenn sie
fordern die forstwirtschaft soll mehr
bäume in ruhe alt werden lassen
der grund dichte naturbelassene wälder
mit viel totholz speichern deutlich mehr
co2
doch die forstwirtschaft werk das ab
wenn sie das holz im wald liegen lassen
was passiert dann dann wird zersetzt was
geht dabei freigesetzten stoffen ich
also als sie kommen ja nicht so aus die
aus dieser nummer raus mit spelmanns
segen schreibt der wissenschaftliche
beirat beim landwirtschaftsministerium
in der aufgabe der forstlichen nutzung
von wäldern seen die beiräte keine
langfristig geeignete maßnahme des
klimaschutzes diewald ökologen feser und
ibis sehen das ganz anders
nur wo die forstwirtschaft gut bleiben
abgestorbene bäume liegen als inseln für
seltene arten totholz speichert wasser
kühlt den wald
außerdem dient es als nährstoff für
humusreiche böden die viel co2 speichern
ist ja relativ logisch wenn wir einfach
jetzt nichts täten und die bäume wachsen
würden zusätzlich auch bäume mal
umfallen zu totholz werden dass sich
über jahrzehnte zersetzt würden große
mengen an kohlenstoff gespeichert werden
in diesem wald also das wäre die
effektivste art und weise die wälder zu
nutzen für das was sie besonders gut
können kohlenstoff bayern
holznutzung kann klimaschonend sein wenn
daraus möbel gefertigt oder häuser
gebaut werden holz zum beispiel
stahlträger ersetzt auf den harpstedter
holztagen ist das den meisten klar wenn
holz verbaut ist speichert das ziel zwei
jahre langfristig also zu möbeln
verarbeitet holz ist besser als
kaminholz
es gibt mittlerweile eine konzepte für
hochhäuser aus holz es gibt die ersten
werden auch gebaut aus holz warum nicht
unsere städte als co2 speicher nutzen
einfach doch stattdessen landet immer
mehr holz im ofen ein grund während auf
holzmöbel und holzhäuser der volle
mehrwertsteuersatz von 19 prozent fällig
wird gilt für brennholz der ermäßigte
steuersatz 7 prozent zusätzlich fördert
das bundeswirtschaftsministerium
holzheizungen bisher mit etwa einer
milliarde euro
kürzlich stoppte das ministerium die
forderung sogar auf bis zu 45 prozent
der kosten auf und heizt die nachfrage
nach feuerholz weiter an
doch das mantra von der
klimafreundlichen holzverbrennung es ist
ein weit verbreitetes missverständnis
das hat auch damit zu tun dass wald
positiv besetzt ist holz ein ein
wunderbarer stoff ist und irgendwie gibt
es offenkundig diesen psychologischen
kurzschluss das alles ein tolles
passiert entsprechend grünes und richtig
und das ist falsch
die folgen sind zu sehen beispielsweise
in osteuropa selbst unberührte wälder
wie hier in rumänien fallen der
holznachfrage zum opfer auch deutschland
importiert inzwischen brennholz und das
problem wird größer werden
das größte kraftwerk englands tracks wo
früher kohle verbrannt wurde kommen
heute holzpellets zum einsatz
in europa rüsten immer mehr
kohlekraftwerke auf biomasse um mit
subventionen im namen des klimaschutzes
hergestellt wird der brennstoff aus
frischen baumstämmen
mit klimaschutz habe das nichts mehr zu
tun meint wolfgang kuhlmann
weltweit würden naturwälder gerodet
luftaufnahmen von einem kahlschlag
gebiet north carolina
dort wo da die pellets herkommen gerade
auch im südosten der usa werden
naturwälder im großen stil in plantagen
umgewandelt plantagen die im endeffekt
weniger co2 speichern als die wälder
vorher deutsche kohlekraftwerke wie
moorburg in hamburg verfeuern bisher
keine pellets doch das könnte sich
ändern wenn der co2 preis auf kohle
steigt und die holzverbrennung so
rentabel wird muss eine klare regelung
dafür geben welches welche art von holz
eigentlich in die energieerzeugung gehen
darf und das können eigentlich nur
reststoffe sein
die anderweitig vorher benutzt worden
sind genau so sehen das auch die
waldexperten feser untypisch sie fordern
forstwirtschaft reduzieren frisches holz
nicht verbrennen mehr wälder in ruhe
lassen
die können ad hoc ab jetzt einfach in
wesentlichen teilen sich selbst
überlassen werden damit sie co2 binden
in als kohlenstoffspeicher um über
jahrzehnte kohlenstoff zu binden der
nicht mehr luft ist waldnutzung im sinne
des klimaschutzes
[Musik]